[Music]
done
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
the regular season is over but mock
draft season is just beginning we are on
to the draft here at bleacher report
especially for those of you that are
rooting for teams that will not be
playing in the postseason so i'm connor
rogers we had a blast the last time we
did this in november but decided to make
it a little bit better this time i got
an old friend with me the man the man of
the people greg ivory is joining we're
gonna make sure your voices are heard
today last time flew through the pics
answered some questions at the end this
time we're gonna have that comment
section rolling we want to hear your
voice we want to hear your reactions to
the pic we want to hear the pics that
you want to see made so greg how we
feeling man let's get into this thing
soon what do you say
feeling really good connor feeling
really good uh you guys know why i'm
here i'm a man of the people this is
right here is the handy dandy ipad and i
need you guys to fill these comments up
fill them up hey if i say one of your
comments you're walking away with a br
gridiron hoodie there it is my boy
connor got it right there there it is
hey fill those comments up
that's right everybody get into it uh
even if you hate the pick i don't care i
could take it we're here for it we want
to hear what you want your team to do
let's waste no time we know who's on the
clock already guess what they were on
the clock number one last year in those
jacksonville jaguars and while they got
what they hope is their franchise
quarterback of the future in the 2021
draft this year in 2022 we're looking on
the other side of the ball and not a big
surprise here mckayvon thibodeaux from
oregon somebody that just has a lot of
traits that you cannot teach the speed
the bend off the edge the power is
getting better the flexibility and
really a fully functional pass rush plan
you saw the long arm move there he can
win the outside corner he can bull rush
and he can counter inside and he's
starting to figure it out against the
run as well so when you look at
thibodeau he's already had the
production he's done it since he was a
true freshman at oregon he's done it for
three years but on top of that he has
elite athleticism i don't think this
draft has a miles garrett a chase young
or even necessarily a nick bosa but
thibodeau is an excellent prospect he's
only getting better and for jacksonville
that's what they need they need to turn
the corner this roster needs to improve
and you get somebody that can be a
defensive franchise cornerstone with the
number one overall pick so number two
moving on to the detroit lions and i
think everybody knows what's gonna
happen here they are gonna keep aiden
hutchinson home in the state of michigan
this is a no-brainer for them right now
they were at number one the conversation
becomes a little bit more difficult with
thibodeau there at number two this feels
like a layup where they get a franchise
changing pass rusher and hutchinson who
from a production standpoint had a
better year than thibodeau this year
maybe not a better college career but a
better 2021 season helped that program
get over the hump and take down their
rival in ohio state for the first time
in a long time hutchinson is a very
twitchy pass rusher that can do it
standing up he can also play with his
hand in the dirt he knows how to win
with power his effort is unbelievable
non-stop and i think that's not the last
time we're going to talk about that
michigan defensive line in this draft so
the lions kind of a no-brainer selection
there now greg i'm calling these
no-brainers i'm calling thibodeaux
number one overall the jacksonville
hutchinson number two overall do the
comments feel the same is anybody
banging the table for evan neal does
anybody want those picks to be reversed
they think hutchinson's number one and
thibodeau's dropped where are the
comments going right now as we kick off
these first two picks
that's super funny you brought up neil
i'm in the comments m matt says neil
would be a better pick for the jags
connor mike hi and matt you are walking
away with a br gridiron hoodie uh
the comments are all over the place
connor the comments are over all over
the place uh here we go i got he looked
like a high schooler versus them dogs uh
i think they're talking about your boy
hutchison they're going second uh but it
seems like the comments are all over the
place
i like your mock draft connor i like
these first two picks i like the i like
the guy from oregon um i think that
since freshman year he's been bawling so
i can see him going number one i like
these picks conor and it seems like the
audience is doing the same
yeah and shout out to whoever said
though that evan neal at number one
maybe jacksonville can trade out a
number one with one of the next two
teams we're talking to talk about the
texans and the jets who can definitely
use an edge rusher for themselves and
jacksonville would still end up with
evan neal so i like the thinking there
right i'm open to a difference of
opinion on this one but let's keep this
thing rolling right now houston texans
are on the clock at number three and
this is really where the draft gets
started it feels like those top two pass
rushers are gonna be talked about as one
and two but if you think this guy is the
best player in the draft and kyle
hamilton from notre dame you're not
crazy he is an excellent excellent
prospect a do it all safety kind of
player on the back end or in the box he
can match up with tight ends slot
receivers he can attack downhill against
the run or he could sit in a deep zone
where he shows off excellent sideline to
sideline range against the intermediate
and deep passes so
nick casario he comes from that new
england background they put a big time
premium on top flight defensive backs
and whether it's safety whether it's
corner they value that very very heavily
kyle hamilton in this situation is
probably the best player on the board so
if the texans don't look to move up or
one of those pass rushers doesn't fall
hamilton is a pretty safe pick for them
to really turn this thing around all
right number four the new york jets who
pick twice in the top 10 of this draft
and they are not the only new york team
that will do that now they're in an
interesting situation they would have
loved either of those pass rushers at
the top so maybe they do pick up the
phone and try to get there to land one
of them
makai bechten hasn't played since week
one serious injury they have morgan
moses expected to hit free agency george
fan entering the final year of his
contract joe douglas if there is
anything we've learned about you he
values the offensive line more than
anything and they have to protect their
young quarterback and zach wilson so
we're going to look at evan neal here
from alabama their left tackle who the
story with neil is besides how big how
athletic and how tough he is he played
he started at guard left guard in 2019
right tackle in 2020 and now left tackle
for the crimson tide who were in the
national championship in 2021 so
offensive line versatility with neil
he's a mauler especially right down
there at the goal line he does not get
beat very often in pass protection he is
really a cornerstone for any offensive
line in a really really good class you
can have a conversation about ikemekwanu
here charles cross i think they are very
closely graded to neil but why this
makes sense for the jets once again is
that positional versatility of okay
you're unsure about beckton's future or
you like fan at left tackle well neil
can play on the right side if you like
both those guys back next year well then
neil can start his career at guard so
joe douglas he's always going to take
his swings on the offensive line
we know that pretty pretty safely so
staying with new york football right now
the giants are on the clock and
their offensive line needs a lot of work
so we're going to bring up somebody that
i just mentioned is in play for the jets
and ikemekwanu who's just had a
phenomenal year at nc state was really
under recruited but now has developed at
a rapid pace he has some of the best run
blocking film you'll ever watch his
tenacity sets a different tone up front
andrew thomas looked a lot better for
this team this year but the giants
offensive line still has significant
holes even with the strides that he's
made it doesn't matter if daniel jones
or joe judge are in the future the new
gm and they have a long list of
candidates they're going to view has to
come in and land foundational pieces
that's exactly what equanu is he might
end up being the highest rated offensive
tackle when all is said and done when
everybody gets through the tape and we
get through the testing okay we're
getting this offensive line run is going
we are on to the panthers right now and
i said there's the big three you got
neal you got aquanu
charles cross is still on the board from
mississippi state and charles cross and
the panthers go together like peanut
butter and jelly this is a franchise
that needs a franchise left tackle their
pass protection on the edge especially
on the left side has simply got to
improve and this was the best pass
protector in the country this year cross
is silky smooth he's got light feet he's
a dancing bear he can mirror pass
rushers i think he's got plenty of juice
in the run game but his calling trey is
being a lights out pass protector on an
island and listen they've already
committed to sam darnold with the fifth
year option we know that maybe they
draft someone or sign a veteran to give
him some competition next year but
knowing that you have that much of a
volatile quarterback situation then you
have to invest in everything around them
and to me that is charles cross he once
again he is a no a bona fide top 10 pick
nobody's talking about him that way but
he should be a lock especially with how
offensive line needy these teams are in
these early picks all right the giants
are back on the clock again you didn't
have to wait that long giants fans you
got an answer for your offensive line
how about you keep adding to your
defensive line it looks like they hit on
azizo jalari their second round pick
from last year but he needs help across
from him and we're going to go with
george karloff this the edge rusher from
purdue more of a power player he's got a
good first step he's got excellent hands
and that really packs a punch he's
technically sound the active hands not
overly twitchy but the consistent effort
is what is valuable especially as a
power rusher he keeps working he's pro
ready against the run and he has he's
given tackles a tough time even since
his freshman and sophomore season so
karl loftus the nfl's version of the
greek freak that's right he is from
greece came over here and has developed
into an incredible american football
player uh carloftus for the giants is
one of those trenches picks that's just
too easy to make the giants got to get
better in the trenches on both sides of
the ball and they got to get tougher
they need to be a tougher team they
haven't been a competitive football team
for much of this season iguanu karloftis
that sets a different edge no matter who
the coach is all right we've rattled off
a ton of picks here two of them going to
the giants greg let's check in what are
where the vibes at right now is
everybody keeping calm and rational i'm
sure
connor everybody is keeping calm but the
new york giants fans i think they want
two offensive linemen uh on this draft
they want two offensive linemen i got
big walk dogs saying giants have to
double up on the o line and i also got
new york in 613 they says giants need
two offensive linemen and not worry
about the line any more so it seems like
it seems like they wanna the the fans
are leaning towards the trenches but
they're leaning towards the offensive
side connor what do you think about that
i think they're right they're sick of
watching their offensive line flat out
get dominated for years now now what
i'll tell giants fans to calm the nerves
i know you're in a difficult cap
situation but maybe there are some low
budget free agent additions or a trade
out there you swap some money you get a
veteran on that offensive line to go
with these young guys i don't think you
want to go into next year with you know
only third year andrew thomas and two
rookies starting i get it you'd be a lot
better for it in the future the long
term but maybe if they can land a
veteran use that first pick on offensive
line and then you can get the pass
rusher and karloftis but i feel them i
totally get it giants fans are going to
want tyler linderbaum as well and
they're not wrong all right let's keep
this thing moving we are on to the
falcons and we are keeping with the pass
rushers here now take everything i said
about car loftus right the power the
active hands that that really just a
bully of a player a hard-nosed player
but not as flexible and twitchy as a
speed rusher now it's the opposite with
david ojaba who's going to the falcons
here the name of the game for him is
speed you can see he's more of a slender
true stand-up rusher but that outside
speed and ability to turn the corner and
you see it with the strip sack there
and he really has not been playing
football for that long where the ceiling
for him is so so high working progestic
progress against the run michigan didn't
keep him on the field as much as they
did like a guy with hutchinson but his
highs as a rusher that ability streams
home run ceiling and it's no secret the
falcons pass rush was one of the worst
in football so yes they missed out on
thibodeau hutchinson car loftus but
ojabo has been one of the biggest risers
in the entire draft process so far i
think after his combine that's only
going to continue all right
broncos are on the clock and we have our
first quarterback selection of the draft
not a great quarterback class but there
are some viable options and the broncos
get their first choice here and we're
going to go with kenny pickett a player
that really reminds me of derek carr
both the highs and the lows would pick
it and you see him throw on the move
there i'm a big fan of his accuracy yes
he's an older prospect he's been with
the pit program for quite some time
really the two questions for pickett are
going to be that age which is really
just is his ceiling tapped out and his
hand size his hands are going to come in
below 9 inches which is a complete
outlier through the draft process but
they don't affect his accuracy he looks
like the most pro ready quarterback of
this class he does a good job scanning
the field he's a really good touch
thrower and he showed teams that had
questions about his athleticism
athleticism this year that he can make
things happen with his legs not
necessarily just as a runner and we all
saw the fake slide heard around the
world but more so extending plays with
his legs and opening up that
intermediate to deep pass game so the
broncos we know all the weapons they
have and they got them under contract
they got cortland sutton jerry judy tim
patrick noah fan javonte williams one of
the best young runners in the entire
league they need an option better than
drew luck or teddy bridgewater and i
think pickett can do that honestly it
might be a little bit of a reach but at
the end of the day they just need
somebody that can come in and be an
upgrade all right the new york jets are
back on the clock we had them go with
evan neal with the fourth overall pick
we're gonna stay on the offensive side
of the ball and help out zach wilson and
we're going with our first wide receiver
off the board here and traylin burks
from arkansas
at six foot two 230 pounds he's got
gigantic hands to catch everything his
hand size is about the 93rd percentile
so this guy is just simply built
different you see it on the jet sweep
you see his ability as a runner he's
excellent in every phase of the catch he
is a contested catch monster he can
catch the ball in traffic he can win
one-on-one on the outside they use him
in the slot they use even use him as an
h-back so for traelin burks he's a great
fit for this team because you know who
led the jets and contested catches this
year that would be corey davis with only
six per pro football focus that is an
alarming number that means that these
receiving targets are not helping out
zach wilson when the ball is in the air
down the field that is what traelin
burks is excellent at okay i know jets
fans are gonna want more help on a
defense that really really struggled
they have a lot of cap dollars and more
picks to fix that i think you use your
premium draft assets to entirely help
your young quarterback and you did that
with the offensive line with neil now
you do it at the wide receiver position
with burke so you go into next year with
corey davis elijah moore traelin burks
and we'll see if they re-sign braxton
barrios that's a lot for a young
quarterback like zach wilson to work
with all right time for a great check-in
because i know the comments are
absolutely flying i think pick it's
going to be a little bit of a
controversial pitch so i want to see
where we're at yeah give away some
hoodies and let's let the people be
heard
a little controversial but i'm hearing
uh a name pop up jameson williams i got
swifty 500 says imagine
jameson williams elijah moore and corey
davis sheesh
shout out to you swifty uh i also got
from reasonable doubt reasonable doubt
says the jets need to trade back and
take a mod gardener
wow i also got stark lines in the common
sense jets need to trade back or trade
for jameson
williams uh connor do you think the jets
should trade back here is this a spot
that they should trade back and acquire
more picks
or should they just take a pick with
this pick right here
no i love that greg i do think they
should trade back my question always is
and we have a smart comment section
shout out to swifty i i totally hear you
jameson speed is tremendous the question
is who's going to come up and for what
and maybe when we do do more of these
mock drafts down the road we do create
trades we start to see the bigger
picture with the draft maybe there's a
quarterback riser or two that teams come
up and need i think for the jets and
we know joe douglas loves the trade
whether it's players whether it's moving
back whether it's moving up he did this
last year
i think for you know a lot of teams
they're wondering what is worth it to
come up and for what so in this spot
they stay but the jamison williams
argument for me is totally valid he's
just a different player than burke's
he's a speed guy he's a vertical guy he
got hurt in the national championship
last night we don't have official injury
news yet we're going to see how that
affects his process but i'll tell you
right now he's not going to be on the
board for long and neither is sauce
gardner so let's keep this thing moving
right now we're going to move to the
washington football team and it was a
tough year for the washington football
team because they went in with high
expectations and then ryan pat ryan
fitzpatrick gets hurt right away he's
lost for the season with the hip injury
taylor heineke the heineken roller
coaster man it was tough so
i think they need to zone in on
quarterback the question is who is going
to be there for them if it is gone we're
gonna look at matt corral here now no
doubt this is a little bit of a reach i
don't think a lot of these quarterbacks
are in the same mold as last year's
excellent class but corral is good
enough
to really elevate this washington
offense with scary terry mclaren antonio
gibson and a decent enough offensive
line what i like about corral is he's a
good rhythm thrower decent athleticism
really nice intermediate accuracy and he
can throw with anticipation right he can
throw guys open so
for washington the overall theme here is
and if you don't like corral the theme
is still they need to stop with the half
measures at quarterback right and even
dwayne haskins a couple years ago they
didn't go up and get him there was a lot
of conflict in that front office if he
was the guy or not uh people that
thought he wouldn't work out ended up
being proven right and it was really
there was a lot of divide there then you
go to veteran that's you know been all
around like fitzpatrick didn't work out
because of age now you've got heineken
who's been a nice story but has not been
consistent enough this would signal to
me taking corral in the top 15 or
trading this pick for a veteran passer
that hits the market washington
understands the problem with the root of
their franchise on the field so
next up the minnesota vikings one of
those teams looking for a new coach a
new jam and this pick can change when
those hires are happen right now you
gotta go with derek stingley he's been
on the board a little bit too long now
what i'll say about stingley is why he's
still sitting here and goes outside the
top ten pick number 12
is simply that he's been hurt and the
film has never been as good as when he
was a true freshman in 2019 where he was
a dominant outside corner in 2020 he was
not the same player this year he plays
three games before he's lost for the
year so teams are gonna have questions
on stingling but the questions we don't
have is he's an elite athlete he's got
excellent size he's got excellent ball
skills when he is on the field he is a
true press corner that just disrupts
wide receivers at the line of scrimmage
he can play physical but he's also got
the elusive finesse game down the field
to take away the football so the vikings
need corners the stingley who has the
highest ceiling in this class right not
the not the highest floor the highest
ceiling is on the board it's kind of a
no-brainer a home run swing for whatever
new regime comes in there all right
moving on to the cleveland browns i
think browns fans are going to love this
pick because we're keeping an ohio state
buckeye home and going with garrett
wilson who for me right now
is the highest rated receiver in my eyes
in this draft hammer trailing burst a
little bit of a 1a1b situation just
different players with garrett wilson
he's just excellent at all three phases
of playing wide receiver before during
and after the cash compares to calvin
ridley for me a pro ready route runner a
tremendous body control concentration as
you just saw on the last play he's a
complete bull with the ball in his hands
and his stopping star is truly lethal
especially when you turn on the tape
against rutgers he had a couple moves
after the catch that were truly
exceptional and then you see the stop
and start there the ability to cut back
garrett wilson is a high floor player
that can come in and truly give you a
thousand yards out of the gate we know
how badly the browns need a receiver
this draft works out perfectly with
garrett wilson falling into their lap
all right the baltimore ravens this
might be one of my favorite picks of the
entire mocktrap and we already heard
this name in the comment section it's
sauce gardener time and i'll say this
about sauce gardener he has the best
film of any corner in this class right i
would say maybe the best film of any
defender in this draft over a long haul
right multiple years of being a high-end
shutdown starter that can also do a lot
of different things for you up front you
see him as a blitzer but you see him in
phase at coverage he is a sticky
physical defender he can find the ball
in the air and this year honestly
quarterbacks just stayed away from him
so you look at sauce gardener he in my
eyes is the best corner right now in
this draft stingley has the higher
ceiling but in terms of the fit with the
ravens this is just perfect they love
those physical man-to-man corners they
are going to bring pressure up front
with wink martindale and they're going
to leave their corners without a lot of
help and sauce gardner has lived that
life at cincinnati he's excelled with it
you watch him in the semifinal against
alabama and he showed i don't just do
this in what people view as a smaller
conference i do this against the top
dogs i am ready all right we have
something interesting up ahead we have
the eagles on the clock for back to back
picks and i know the birds fans are
fired up about this strap with three
first-rounders so with something as
special as picking back-to-back had to
call up an old friend and see where his
mind is at what he's thinking for the
eagles
welcome to the cold streets of new york
where a philadelphia guy's got a
question for connor rogers now that the
draft is settling out eagles might get
three picks in the top 20 and jamison
williams gets hurt in the national
championship game
should i hope that the eagles take him
what about my guy from arkansas that
conor knows i love will the eagles be
getting a partner for devonta smith in
this trip love you
always great to hear from the man adam
lefkow and had to get him involved had
to phone him up to see where his mind is
at for the eagles and i'm with him all
the way i'm thinking wide receiver for
this team with the first pick now
trailing burks went to the jets i think
that's a perfect fit for the eagles
we're going to look at jameson williams
now garrett wilson is off the board the
question with williams is going to be
what his injury impact is from the
national championship game but what he
can do on the field there are very few
questions he is the fastest skill player
in this trap elite speed good with the
ball in his hands and a good route
runner you're going to see the
hesitation the stop and start ability to
get down the field
against georgia right he's not just
running by no name defenders he's
running by nfl caliber defenders and i
think for his you know tall slender
build he's tough in the middle of the
field he is tough at the catch point
he's not afraid to play a physical brand
of football so you got devonta smith now
you're bringing in jameson williams you
love what you saw from jalen hurts this
year you feel really good about your
skill group as long as jameson's health
checks out if not they're gonna have to
go in a different direction but they get
to do this back to back so we're gonna
move on to the second pick which is on
the other side of the ball and somebody
who is a national champion right now in
the kobe dean one of my favorite players
in this entire draft a tremendous
off-ball linebacker he's one of the
smartest most physical defenders in this
entire class he gets everyone set before
the snap his pre-snap awareness is
completely off the charts plays with his
hair on fire plays fast a total
nightmare to deal with on all three
downs good luck finding a weakness in
his game right this guy finds the ball
whether it's in coverage whether it's
against the run whether it's as a
blitzer where he wreaked havoc for that
dog's defense this year the kobe dean is
the leader on that field he will be a
leader in the nfl he is a tremendous
tremendous football player we know how
much we all loved roquan smith coming
out of there a few years ago it's the
same story with nakobi dean so for the
eagles they get two players that played
in that national championship game and
two players that can come in and really
really have a key role as rookies right
away all right birds went back to back
time for a little break time to check in
with greg uh we had a left go appearance
we've had a lot going on since our last
great check-in greg what's going on
connor what's happening i'm in the
comments man talking to the people i got
mckringleberry87 says my eagles need
three linebackers they are the worst
core in the league shout out to you
mckringleberry i also got jay stein in
here jay stein in here jay stein says
eagles trade a pick for ridley that is a
question for you connor should the
eagles trade a pick for calvin ridley uh
that's what the people want to know
shout out to both mcringleberry87 and
jamestine23 you guys are walking away
with the hoodie but connor the people
want to know is that a fair trade should
the eagles trade for calvin rayleigh
i think it's a good fit now i don't
think they should trade one of their
first rounders for calvin ridley he's an
excellent player but he missed most of
this year greg so you know looking at it
for the eagles
you are in the driver's seat of this
draft where you can get a great wide
receiver you don't have to give up one
of these picks for a guy that any year
will be 28 and then you've got to pay
them mega dollars and then you're in
this vine you can keep getting younger
and younger and build this long-term
core with smith and jalen and a veteran
offensive line and you have dallas
goddard there for a while so i like the
idea but it won't cost you a first
rounder so i think they're good on that
front um but yeah the comment section i
saw actually some love for the eagles
picks it's it's good to see the comment
section is fired up right now
remember to drop your questions please
remember to drop your questions in the
chat because i'm going to be asking my
guy connor i'm going to be asking him
more frequently now connor you so i hope
you ready bro
let's do it man all right let's keep
this thing moving we got the chargers on
the clock
sorry chargers fans i know your season
ended
as late as it possibly could i feel for
you but it's time to get better it's
time to put all that bad vibes behind
you and let's get a player that can help
this secondary and trent mcduffie from
washington a sticky outside cover corner
probably the most underrated one in this
entire class he didn't make a lot of
plays on the ball but he also didn't
surrender a touchdown the entire year
mcduffie is a a different kind of player
in that he's not a very tall outside
corner but he still plays very physical
very smart so smooth in coverage can
turn his hips can come downhill and
tackle i think he can play in the slot
if you ask him to but i like that he's
already shown it on tape despite his
size limitations that he's been
excellent on the outside so for the
chargers you have a star in justin
herbert right and we're gonna see what
happens to mike williams in free agency
but your offense is going to be fine in
the long run the defense has got to be
better and it starts with the pass
coverage on the back end mcduffie is a
name that if you haven't seen him in the
top 20 yet too many people are sleeping
because he is an excellent excellent
player all right moving on to pick 18
the saints are on the clock and we know
very well what they need they have a lot
of different needs but i start at wide
receiver an area i thought they would
have addressed last year they have to go
into the draft this year and capitalize
on this big group in the first round
crystal lava is the name that comes to
mind for me here he has been so
productive for the buckeyes for a couple
of years now he wins down the field he
tracks the ball extremely extremely well
much like his teammate garrett wilson he
is a pro ready route runner that can get
it done once again at all three phases
of playing the wide receiver position
and there is no learning curve right you
look at jameson williams maybe a bit of
a one-year wonder but you look at
somebody like a lobby
he can come in and start for you right
away and in that saints offense under
sean payton give you big time big time
production all right back to the eagles
okay and i saw some in the comments
saying
we need defense we need defense badly
okay all right you got the wide receiver
then we took nicoby dean we are going
back to defense and we are getting
better up front with the marvin lial
from texas a m a little bit of a tweener
a guy that can play inside outside plays
with power plays with active hands and
has excellent downhill strength so when
you look at liau
this is a front that has gotten a little
older over time yes they still have
fletcher cox yes they've dealt with a
lot of injuries they locked up josh
sweat but they do need to get younger
they do need to add a younger pass rush
maybe milton williams on the inside
gives you some punch next year but
you're picking three times in the first
round get one of the top pass rushers
lial is still struggling to figure out
the run a little bit but when you let
him pin his ears back and go he is an
excellent excellent threat up front so
back on the clock the now on the clock
for the first time the pittsburgh
steelers and we know big ben is riding
off into the sunset this is it for big
ben
are they going to look at a veteran
quarterback are they going to look at
this draft we are waiting are they going
to look at the trade market right are
they going to take a chance on somebody
else
i look at this draft right here where
they're sitting they're in position
where matt corral's gone kenny pickett's
gone how about sam howell from unc a
player that you know kind of came back
down to earth this year when all of his
weapons left but howell is a good
athlete you can throw the ball down the
field when you watch him play you do
think the highs of baker mayfield right
not the injured battered struggling
baker mayfield we saw to finish this
season but more so a player uh that can
has a lot of arm strength packs a big
time punch with the downfield pros but
he really grew as a runner this year and
for the steelers you don't need somebody
to come in and be your hero right big
ben has not been that this year you have
naji harris you have good young wide
receivers you have an excellent young
tight end and pat prior mode and the
offensive line uh you can always get
back to being the strength that it has
been so for hal he doesn't have to come
in and be a hero in this situation he
just needs to come in and run an
effective offense which he's shown on
tape in the past he can do when the
playmakers are there so the steelers
getting their quarterback of the future
gonna be one of the most fascinating
teams to keep an eye on this offseason
because mike tomlin does not deal with
losing seasons ever so are they going to
hand the keys to the car to a rookie or
are they going to look for a veteran in
this situation we have them go howl all
right one more pick before we check in
with greg because that's going to be a
controversial one steelers fans i know
they've really wanted kenny pickett in
this situation he's already gone
we're going to move to the new england
patriots here who went out last free
agency basically bought an offense they
signed two top tied ends they signed
kendrick bourne they got nelson aguilar
i still think they need to get weapons
for mac jones and i'm going to look at
drake london here the best contested
catch threat in this entire class a big
body player his coach and clay helton
compared him to mike evans and you could
see the same body type with drake london
he suffered a season-ending injury but
if he comes back healthy and shows him
workouts he's the same guy he's an
above-the-rim player that is a
quarterback's best friend you see right
there even when covered even when shut
down you can throw the ball up to him
and let him make things happen so i love
drake london as long as he's healthy
he's somebody that you know very similar
to what we've seen mike williams do at
times for justin herbert he can come in
and the quarterback can trust him to go
make a play for him put the ball where
only i can get it and i will go get that
done we know mack jones is a little
limited in terms of the type of player
he is but he's coming and been extremely
efficient and london would only help
that in the future so
greg time for a little check-in we've
knocked out some picks we have a
controversial one with the steelers and
howell i think yes fans will like
i think patriots fans will like drake
london i love how vocal the eagles fans
have been they wanted defense they got
it where are we at right now
yeah connor uh the vibes in the comments
towards the steelers pick is a little uh
how i'll say i got bryce phillips bryce
phillips says that was a horrible pick
for the steelers uh i also got i also
got
dominic here dominic dom schrader says
steelers need an offensive lineman if
they can't secure picket or corral
what are your thoughts i also see
another one up here about the steelers
getting the o-line so connor talk to me
do the steelers need to work or should
they draft to build that o-line
i always agree with that i think
whenever you can get better in the
trenches and they do need to get a
little better in the trenches you go for
that right so
linderbaum's still on the board you have
a player like kenyon green you know you
have somebody uh you know like green
there who can play guard for you you
have a lot trevor penning is a player
that can play tackle for you so there's
options then once again i i kind of
alluded to it with how will being the
next guy up the steelers don't do losing
football maybe there's a veteran option
that they go out there and secure rather
than handing the keys to a rookie so i
understand where they're at greg
now listen to me here listen to me here
i got
keegan08 says you meant veteran you
mentioned veteran now he's not um he's a
veteran he's been in the league for a
couple years dwayne haskins dwayne
haskins
does dewayne haskins have a chance
that's what keegan wants to know does he
have a chance or is it over for him in
pittsburgh
well they would know right they get to
watch him every day so
if they feel that he is the guy and then
they'll go with a lesser option you
could take a quarterback on day two
instead and let them compete them
getting to see haskins all the time
helps them a lot so i don't think
they'll bet the house on that like i
said i think they're going to want a
sure thing a player that can come in and
run the offense and not turn the ball
over that's what they care about i think
that's the direction the steelers will
go unless they can make the splash and
aaron rodgers uh you know really does
hit the market as a trade piece and he
wants to go out there and try to win a
super bowl
got you got you hey i wanna say this
again hey fill these comments up guys
because if i mention you you are walking
away with that sweet sweet
vr gridiron hoodie man so fill these
comments up
all right so a lot of love in there from
the steelers fans for tyler linderbaum
and i feel you because he's a great
player and he's the next pick and it is
the miami dolphins on the clock
they need offensive line help in the
worst way and they especially need it
along that interior linderbaum is one of
the best players in this entire draft
it's as simple as that when you look at
what he's done over the last two years
he's an excellent athlete an incredibly
tough player especially in zone blocking
you see him climb to the second level he
finishes his blocks he plays with an
edge a former state champion wrestler so
you know the kind of attitude he has and
you see the pancake block there
the dolphins are team that are in a
little bit of disarray right now they
move on from brian flores there was a
lot of differing opinions there whether
chris career's draft misses should come
back to you know make him the guy that's
out the door that's all over what
matters is right now this is an
ownership group that is behind tuatang
of iloa and if that's the case you've
got to protect him you've got him help
with jalen waddle but you've got to
protect him the offensive line has not
been good enough and linderbaum is
probably the safest of the entire
offensive line picks in this trap the
dolphins make out like bandits with him
being on the board here at pick 22. all
right the raiders the playoff raiders on
the clock here and those raiders broke
the hearts of chargers fans we're going
to see if they can make some noise in
the playoffs and move this pick but
right now i still think they need more
help in the secondary and we're going to
capitalize on a really good corner class
and look at a guy that just declared in
cair elam from florida now
this was not the season that kyre elam
was hoping to have as florida kind of
unraveled a little bit i thought he was
better in the 2020 season but he's still
a really good player an excellent tackle
tackler a physical press corner but he
can also play off and zone read the
quarterback come downhill and make a
play so when i look at elam i love his
ceiling i love what the underclassmen
tape has presented with him and i think
that he's a physical player that fits
that raiders identity and they got to
get better on the outside of those
corner spots they have max crosby a
total stud up front wreaking havoc i
would have really liked nakobi dean for
them here but he went to the eagles
already i'm always thinking about
drafting pass rushers but with elam this
late in the draft i feel like that's a
really really good value selection for
vegas and we're going to stick with
corner here as the cardinals are on the
clock we're going to look at auburn's
roger mccreery a
physical sticky corner coming out of
auburn that might not be the biggest guy
right you look at stingley and elam
they're about six foot two you look at
mccreer and even sauce gardener a bigger
guy mccreary's right around five eleven
six feet tall a physical player and he's
just so tough to shake free from to be
honest with you he's very fluid in
coverage you can play on the outside i
think he could even play on the inside
the cardinals secondary they still need
that one more piece right if they tried
out the marco wilson experiment this
year they've tried different things i
think they need to invest in the
secondary they have for a while they do
have good pieces and they've looked at
the washington huskies for a lot of
those pieces but in this scenario you go
to an sec pro ready player that can come
in and start i think that defense has
had moments of brilliance this year and
now you go get maybe the final piece for
that group you bring back chandler jones
uh mccreary is one of the most
underrated players in this entire entire
class he's kind of like mcduffie who
earlier we said people just don't know
him because they don't watch corners
that don't get the ball thrown their way
so all right i think we're going to take
another break here greg i hear the
comments are jumping introducing a
couple of new sirs here on the mach
mccreary was not in the november edition
but it's time to learn his name greg
what's going on
i got a question got a question from
josh
joshod1 he says with the raiders do you
think derrick carr
could be on the block conor and i want
to add to that
if he is on the block does that change
the way they go about their draft
process
wow number one he shouldn't be i think
derek carr has given you everything you
could ask of him right now after being
doubted even by me for so long so
no i don't think he'll be on the block
no i don't think he if he did it you can
look differently at the draft here you
have
malik willis on the board still if they
wanted to go for a more mobile option at
quarterback but greg i think no matter
what even if they are looking
at the draftable quarterbacks carr has
to be there next year
got you got you guys fill those comments
up fill those comments up the raiders
fans connor they are jumping in the
comments i just wanted to give you one
question i didn't want to barbarg you
with too much but the raiders fans and
that pick that you made they are jumping
in the comments i think they wanted a
linebacker or safety
yeah and we could speak to that i think
for the raiders they are an interesting
spot where i think that's fair you look
at jordan battle from alabama louisiana
from georgia if you want to go safety i
have them as round two players not round
one players jaquan brisker from penn
state you know there's no kyle hamilton
level player on the board here i saw
some love for linebacker devin lloyd
comes to mind for them and you're going
to hear his name called today so the
raiders fans uh i've been doing the
draft here greg for quite some time and
there is no more passionate group than
those raiders fans in the comments so
i'm sure we'll revisit with them we will
keep this thing moving we are looking at
the bengals
they hit the home run of last year's
draft and jamar chase as their wide
receiver won and might be the wide
receiver one of the national football
league for a long time now they're going
to go for what a lot of people were
screaming for last year and go offensive
line with trevor penning get themselves
a tackle that can keep joe burrow
healthy keep him upright
penning
really really is a guy that plays with
an edge in northern iowa he shows that
he can hang with the big dogs you see
him here against iowa state obviously a
program with plenty of talent and he
showed that he can hang and he's going
to do that at the senior bowl this year
i like him in pass bro he's got a long
big frame with a big big wingspan that
can survive on the outside of the nfl
loves to finish his blocks the bengals
just need to get a little tougher in the
trenches and penning is the guy to bring
that he's even better than spencer brown
their his teammate that went to the
bills and has started for that good
phil's mafia team this year so penning
maybe not the most popular first round
player but one of those safer picks that
you look at and gets you better in the
trenches for a team that needs help
there all right speaking of the bills
mafia and speaking of their offensive
line kenyon green the guard from texas a
m who
is just an absolute bully before the
season a lot of people projected him as
a potential top 10 kick it hasn't really
worked out a tackle but he is a
tremendous player on the inside of guard
he is a mauler he's nasty he's generates
incredible power from his lower body so
we look at the bills
they play some nasty cold weather games
and they got to develop a consistent
rushing attack to help out josh allen
who is an absolute superstar i look at
green and go they just need pieces for
their offensive line he's played
everywhere he's literally played left
tackle left guard right guard right
tackle he's never played center but they
don't need him to do that with morse
there so for the bills here this is
about capitalizing on value and helping
out your offensive line that is aging in
a couple of spots a couple of those
spots might hit free agency soon enough
kenyan green's incredible value here all
right moving on to the lions this uh
this pick should have the comment
section jumping so if you want one of
those hoodies continue to make some
noise continue to complain i don't care
do whatever you want it's fun that way
the lions are looking for their
quarterback of the future here and going
with malik willis one of the most
exciting players in this entire draft
his ability as a runner his ability as a
vertical passer the decision making
still needs to get better he you know
obviously played at a smaller program at
liberty after transferring out of auburn
so he obviously was at a big time
program ends up transferring really
molds his career now we'll be playing at
the senior bowl could show everybody the
kind of talent he has he's not the same
runner as lamar jackson i don't want
people to make that confident comparison
i think that's a little unfair but he's
a very exciting player and you can get
creative with him at the goal line
and why i like this fit with the lions
so much is they already have jared goff
there that can play if you want to give
him a leak some time on the bench we saw
the niners do that with trey lance this
year you know we've seen a lot of teams
do that over time
with young quarterbacks i think that's
good for malik willis to sit back learn
and then you can even get him involved
in a red zone package early on because
of how much of a dynamic player he is at
the goal line so the lions they made out
like bandits they got aiden hutchinson
at number two now they get malik willis
at 27. we'll do one more pick
oh you actually know what let's check in
with greg because that's one of those
picks that
i think everybody's been waiting for
everybody loves themselves and malik
willis
connor uh the comments want to know and
my guy don witch wants to know we just
talked quarterback in the last pick we
want to know which quarterback has the
highest ceiling in this draft
it's malik willis for me and i see some
people in there saying desmond ritter uh
you know ritter's a fine player i worry
about his accuracy a little bit and he
might sneak into the first round i won't
have him in this first round for me
it'll be corral pickett howell and malik
willis and i think after free agency and
trades four quarterbacks won't even make
it to the first round willis has the
highest ceiling he's an excellent
athlete an excellent runner he's got all
the arm strength in the world his
ability to push the ball vertically down
the field with velocity like i said you
give him more time you give him more
reps you build an offense for him that
allows him to threaten as a runner push
the ball vertically work off of play
action you'll be really happy with what
you can get out of him you know we've
seen greg roman do an excellent job with
lamar jackson uh in baltimore utilizing
his legs we've seen a lot of teams kyler
murray obviously josh allen with the
bills the way the nfl is going guys are
at least threatening linebackers and
defensive lineman with their legs malik
willis is excellent at that all right
greg anything else we got going on in
there or we uh we moving on
let's move on connor let's move on uh i
got something nice i got something nice
coming up but let's move on
okay all right moving on to uh
one of the most excited fan bases every
year and they got to be excited with
where their team's at right now the
dallas cowboys and boys this draft
worked out perfectly for them because
the big man jordan davis has fallen
right into their lap this would allow
them to get tougher in the interior of
their defensive line shut down the run
and a lot of people are probably sitting
here going why is a player like jordan
davis
making it all the way to pick 28 and
what i'll say is he played 378 of their
snaps this year right and his teammate
to kobe dean the linebacker played
nearly 700 so for davis right now he's a
true rotational player and it's not lack
of ability it's more so just stamina so
you gotta wonder do you take a a guy
that is not an every down kind of piece
in the top 15
we'll wait to see if that happens but
for the cowboys here they make out
tremendously by landing davis beef up
that interior you got playmakers on the
back end like diggs i'd like to get them
to safety i thought about jordan battle
here i thought about louisiana for the
cowboys i think they'll be able to
address that if not in free agency but
in the middle of this draft while you're
taking an excellent talent in jordan
davis here greg
where is the comment section at right
now the cowboys are always jumping off
they always got great opinions on where
they want their team to go let's hear
from them right now yes sir
yes sir i got a justin atkinson says no
way jordan davis falls to number 28. uh
shout out to you uh also connor i got i
got toss 21 in here toss21 wants to know
as a cowboys fan do you think they
should draft a replacement for tyron
smith
on that offensive line do you think they
should replace him in this draft
well i think the problem it's a great
question because you always have to
think about your offensive line a year
or two ahead not when oh we have a hole
now we're screwed so i think it's fair
but the problem is the way the board
fell the offensive line run was just too
crazy here so i i think it didn't fall
that way for them and i do see a lot of
the comments saying
you know how does jordan davis make it
here and i can't emphasize enough it
comes down to snap count he's an
excellent player at what he does but you
know if you have a guy that's on the
field for about 60 50 of your snaps
there's a chance that he falls and for
cowboys fans be excited about that and
if he doesn't uh then i get it because
he's an excellent excellent player but
it's a unique situation it's a perfect
fit for them scheme-wise i like where
their heads are at thinking about that
offensive line maybe in round two you
can you know draft it darian canard
would come to mind he's played on the
right side
i would have liked penning for them a
lot but he went to the bengals earlier
so the cowboys instead uh land a talent
that also is in need and they'll think
about offense on day two
connor i got one more for you about
these cowboys one more one more i told
you guys they're always jumping yeah
you gave me the heads up and they are
jumping in the comments jay bernowitz
says connor would jordan davis make the
cowboys the best overall defense in the
nfl
i mean can you imagine micah parsons and
jordan davis in the front together it's
insane to think about
i think it would come down to what they
can do on the back end right can they
get a ball hawking safety to complete
that and there's going to be a couple of
them in free agency like i said i got
about four of them on day two of the
strap that are pro ready plug and play
starters so
be excited cowboys fans if jordan davis
fell into your lap in this situation you
address the safety position and you have
probably a guy who could be the best
defensive player in the nfl for the next
six years and micah parsons yeah you got
a real shot
like that like that connor let's keep
this thing going man all right
let's keep it rolling the chiefs are on
the clock and they get one of my
favorite players they're looking at
linebacker here and going with devin
lloyd from utah this guy just plays
all three downs once again really with
his hair on fire just a maniac truly out
of control but in control somebody that
can take away the football through the
air he's a great run and chase
linebacker against the run he can shoot
gaps he can blitz he sees things
extremely well the effort is off the
charts he does such a good job of
keeping blockers off of him whether it's
with the speed whether it's with his
hands working through traffic this is
some of the best tape you'll watch for
this entire draft class because he can
really do it all he once again it's you
know he's not obviously no one is micah
parsons but when you look at lloyd and
dean what they were asked to do they
were asked to rush they were asked to
cover and they were asked to be
responsible against the run while
keeping those other two things in mind
and they never lost the step they never
looked out of place they actually
excelled they took away the football
they made an impact they are true first
round linebackers i know the position
has lost some of its value in eyes
evaluator eyes over the years those two
guys have to be in that conversation and
for the chiefs it's about just making
your defense better a more competitive
defense lloyd can set a new tone for you
for the next half of decade at least all
right
speaking of super bowl champions we've
gotten through the chiefs now we're
going to move on to the bucks and it's
unfortunate what they've dealt with at
wide receiver this year they lost chris
godwin to injury they lost antonio brown
for just walking out shirtless they need
to continue to build the weapons as tom
brady gets older and older and older and
we're going to take a value pick here in
jahan dodson an excellent speed wide
receiver knows how to get open plays
bigger than his size
you see the excellent hands can track
the ball in the air very elusive player
he's kind of this year's elijah moore
right we watched elijah more tumbled to
the beginning of round two last year
everybody's looking at dobson and
wondering is that going to happen and i
just simply think he's too good now
and you see the body control in the
footwork there
i gave the same spiel about more last
year where i thought the saints of the
packers wouldn't let him buy and maybe
they shouldn't have when all is said and
done i don't know if the nfl makes that
mistake at the end of round one this
year with dotson i don't care about his
size he's gonna run in the four threes
once again he's just a total playmaker
you can get him screens you can get him
going vertically we know the bucks are
going to do pretty well with that so the
bucks you got to love your new piece at
wide receiver especially if you're
unable to pay chris godwin after the
season and you're worried about his
injury all right two picks left
tennessee titans a number one seed in
this year's playoffs and we're going to
look at a need that is kind of quiet for
them because their front has been really
good but i want to get the more pass
rush help here and go with trayvon
walker i could not let him out of this
first round in this in today's mock trap
you see the power there and you saw the
effort last night the chase down tackles
he's got very strong hands he can bull
rush he plays very aware as you can see
the ability to cut back and chase down
so walker is somebody that can play five
tech i think he could even bulk up and
play pre-tech he's about 275 pounds he's
excellent coming downhill i think his
run defense has gotten a lot better this
year but his ability as a pass rusher
effort rusher mike brabel knows a little
bit about that so for trayvon walker
here for the titans
there's a lot of directions they could
have gone they could have added to their
offensive line we didn't like how the
board fell julio jones has been banged
up and getting older aj brown's a star
but you want the future a wide receiver
with them they got sniped by the bucks
here with no dots in so there's no wide
receiver on the board as much as i would
have loved to go wide receiver maybe
they can get creative in free agency
address wide receiver then go best
player available in this situation
that's exactly what they do in trayvon
walker so
last pick and then we're going to get to
greg we're going to get to your
questions your roasts whatever you want
to do it's okay we're here we're having
fun the packers are on the clock with
the final pick and we're going to go
with edge rusher again but in a totally
different mode than trayvon walker we're
looking at drake jackson a stand up
speed rusher very very twitchy you can
see the change of direction right there
the short area quickness he's got
outside speed the ability to turn the
corner now
for jackson
and this wasn't the season at usc that a
lot of people projected him to have they
they thought he could be you know more
in the george carlofta's tier right
outside hutchinson and thibodeaux it
hasn't worked out that way but he is a
ball of clay really moldable with tons
of great traits you're going to see the
outside rush here and that little
shoulder dip and the ability to close in
on the quarterback would be long strides
uh drax jackson is somebody that his
best football is ahead of him when you
look at green bay they've gone down this
road before rashaan gary was a pick that
i questioned i saw great athlete great
size college production didn't exist
jackson's gonna have a little bit of a
similar story green bay's not afraid to
take those guys develop them behind
veterans slowly work them into the mold
and then have their defensive line of
the future in year two year three i
think that's what the situation is going
to be for jackson so
we made it through every single pick of
the first round if you're still here
thank you and if you're still here you
still have a shot to get a hoodie fill
up that and fill up those comments let's
get the questions in right you see the
pace we move out how are we feeling
right now it's your first mock drive
it's definitely not your last uh how are
we doing over there right now
feeling really good connor i actually
have a question for you i saw no tight
ends taken in the first round i just
want to ask you what is that what is
that class like in this year's draft
ironically and i'm really glad you asked
this greg it's a good group the problem
is there's no kyle pitts right everybody
goes oh no first round tight end is this
a bad class and that's not the case it's
a really really strong class it's just
that all of them will probably go in
rounds two to three and the list is long
trey mcbride's the best one at a
colorado state good blocker good
receiver pretty good athlete some of the
best hands in the entire draft you have
jeremy rucker from ohio state excellent
run blocker jalen wademeyer from texas a
m
some questionable drops on tape but also
some big time plays charlie kohler from
iowa state cole turner from nevada
daniel bellinger from san diego state
this is a really really good group greg
isaiah likely from coastal carolina we
got blockers we got past catchers
there's a ton of them in the top 100
really none in the top 32. it's kind of
funny how that works out but i project
at least five of these guys to be week
one starters so if you're looking for a
tight end don't panic that you didn't
get it round one you got a great shot at
it on day two
good value in the second day
tight end pick up uh
connor i got questions from the audience
got questions from the people uh
starting off with austin scott 117 he
says who is rb1 this year
yeah for me it's going to be isiah
spiller from texas a m and another
position we're running back no names in
the first round but it doesn't mean that
there's not talent i mean when you look
at the board here i love isaiah spiller
i love bruce hall from iowa state
kenneth walker from michigan state these
guys all run with power they have big
frames they can break tackles at the
second level the field really really
good acceleration and there's a really
good amount of pass catching backs as
well and some of them will be at the
senior bowl you look at james cook who
had a big run for georgia last night so
this running back class
doesn't pack the round one punch that
last years did you had naji harris
unfortunately travis etm was lost for
the year but he went in the first round
but it has that day two potential we've
seen jonathan taylor alvin kamara
you know even day three aaron jones
players like that we've seen really good
star running backs going rounds two
through seven and that's going to be the
story of this year's draft as well
connor we just wrapped up the end of the
first round so this question
fits
perfectly
with us wrapping the end of the first
round i got b
peltly26 he says which team do you see
making a move to get in in the back end
of the draft
to address a qb spot so i think he meant
which team do you see jumping into the
first round to the end of the first
round to address their qb situation
it's a great question you look at it if
the broncos value a different position
there they can come back up because of
them picking so early they pick 40th in
round two so they can come back up
you know a lot of teams that you would
think in the past are now gonna roll
with their second year players obviously
the bears won't be picking in round one
don't have to worry about a team like
that a lot of teams have veterans that
don't have picks when you look at the
rams they don't have a first round pick
the lions are in the back end of round
one they would make the most sense but
they're already in the back end of round
one because of the trade of matt
stafford so i look at the teams that we
actually had to take quarterbacks today
and some of the comments didn't like the
value and i agree with them i don't like
the value either i don't love this
quarterback class but part of this is
what i want to do and part of this is
what i think the league is going to do
and we see reaches on quarterbacks every
single year so i i did think sam howell
went early today i did think that even
kenny pickett went a little early today
can those teams strategize the broncos
washington you know the steelers can
they sit back strategize and go we're
not going to use a top 20 pick we're
going to use our day two picks to come
back into round one i love where the
thinking is out there
connor you know i cannot get out of here
without talking about my niners i didn't
see a first round pick it's it we gave
it to the dolphin we traded away to the
dolphins trey lance uh so talk to me
we're struggling that cornerback do you
see us going to go grab
a corner two corners maybe three in this
year's draft
yeah i like where your head's at greg i
think it's got to be cornerback now we
saw a lot of really good ones come off
the board today already but not all of
them darion kendrick who played for
georgia last night won a national title
uh played at clemson at a high level
before transferring to the dogs i like
darion kendrick for your team a lot i
think he's one of those longer corners
that can play zone he can play man you
could do a lot of different things with
him i think he'd be comfortable in cover
three so i look at the niners i believe
they're picking 53rd overall they're
going to be in the second round i think
they're going to be in range for a
player like kendrick and then there's a
lot of later on options in this in this
trap right you have kobe bryant from
cincinnati that sauce gardener's
teammate he played at a really really
high level uh you look at a day three
sleeper tariq woolen from utsa so this
is a pretty good corner group greg even
without that first round pick i think
the niners can get a starter at the
position on day two
that's good that's great uh connor
before we wrap it up before we wrap it
up the people want to know i want to
know and my man peyton taylor
wants to know who is your biggest
sleeper
in this year's draft
wow biggest sleeper always tough it's
always hard to dictate what actually
constitutes a sleeper in this world i'll
go with jayvon hiley from coastal
carolina a wide receiver that it does
everything
you know able to get on the field right
away and what i mean by that is catches
everything runs pro ready routes short
area quickness might not run a 4 3 40
and wow you with the blazing down field
speed but what can you do in the 10 to
20 yard range right what can you do in
the zero to 10 yard range for
quarterbacks i look at jayvon hailey
who's going to be at the shrine game so
didn't get the senior bullet invite but
instead he was going to vegas for the
shrine game kind of one of those guys
that you'll hear his name called in
round five round six you'll watch them
in pre-season go for 100 yards and
touchdown and go why is this guy making
all this noise i heard nothing about him
in the winter or spring and then by year
three i mean greg we're seeing it with
hunter renfro right now who we saw on a
higher stage of college football but
nobody thought he'd be doing this
kylie's been excellent for coastal
carolina one of my favorite sleepers in
this draft
love it connor love it uh
hey i think that's the end i gave away
everybody that i mentioned you are
walking away with a br gridiron hoodie i
want you guys to know that but uh connor
i think that's that's the end man i
think yeah that's a wrap it's been fun
thank you to everybody that stuck
through every pick whether you loved it
whether you hated it no hard feelings
here that's why we do this and maybe
we'll change it up we will change it up
next time not necessarily to the
preferred choice but something different
a huge thank you to greg it was awesome
having him here uh filter those comments
get in on the action he will be back
when we do more of these mock drafts and
we will announce it we love it get
involved in the comment section and
we'll do more of these we'll take notice
of your picks and we'll catch you guys
next time
[Music]
you